[Música]
o tema central da minha vida tem sido a
comida eu vou explicar porque em três
histórias
a primeira história se passa às vésperas
da segunda guerra mundial numa pequena
cidade chamada don't prova entre a
alemanha ea polônia
lá havia uma menina loira de cabelos
encaracolados e olhos azuis com 14 anos
chamada marca
ela era a terceira filha de uma família
de judeus que viviam numa casa grande de
tijolos com muitos quartos muitos
quadros e muitos empregados
um dos empregados da casa era um rapaz
de 17 anos olhos verdes forte chamado
michel
ele era o faz-tudo da casa e ele tinha
uma paixão secreta não correspondida por
magnata magda nem sabia de sua
existência
os alemães invadem a polônia
a família de magda perde todos os seus
bens
eles são presos e mandados projeto de
dom prova onde passam a morar no
quartinho apertado escuro
de lá eles são transportados de trem no
campo de concentração de auschwitz onde
começam a passar muito frio e muita fome
a família de magda em austin é
exterminada 1 a 1 na câmara de gás
magda por diversas vezes vai ter fila da
câmara de gaia e milagrosamente ela
sobrevive
magda passa a ser o número 50 950
tatuado em seu braço
magda fica presa em auschwitz dos 14 aos
18 anos quando acabar a guerra ela está
pesando 30 quilos
michel por sua vez pode para a sibéria
com seu irmão mais novo onde também
passam muito frio e muita fome
o irmão de michel pega uma pneumonia e
não sobrevive
michel então é preso e mandado para o
campo de trabalho forçado onde lá
algumas vezes dão pra ele
batata pra comer todos os tipos de
batata e uma família que teve o filho
morto na guerra dá pra ele um casar
assim
por sorte michel sobrevive
quando acaba a guerra michel volta para
a prova sua cidade natal a procura de
alguém que ele conhecesse toda a sua
família morreu e então prova ele escuta
falar que magda seu antigo amor tinha
sobrevivido mas ela foi mandada para
munique
o campo de refugiados rapidamente
michel vai para munique e procura nas
listas de sobrevivente o nome de magda
michel e magda se reencontram
eles se casam e eles têm uma filha
chamada eva
eles decidem que não querem ficar na
alemanha pós guerra
eles pensam em ir para israel que os
estados unidos mas por terem parentes
distantes no brasil eles resolvem que
vão pegar o navio na terceira classe de
um navio passando fome e vão para o rio
de janeiro é avó é minha mãe porque eu
tô contando essa história e porque essa
história pra mim é tão importante
primeiro porque é uma história real
ela é uma linda história de amor pra
mostrar que improvável pode acontecer e
que a sorte pode estar do nosso lado mas
que para isso tudo aconteça a gente tem
que ter muita garra muita coragem e
confiança
essa foto é de uma família totalmente
improvável de acontecer é meu avô michel
com a minha avó magda os seis bisnetos
a minha mãe eva
quem fez neto e meu avô michel antes de
morrer me disse que o que fez ele
sobreviver não foram nem os casacos e
nem a batata e sim ele perceber que
através da batata ainda existe amor
apesar de tudo que ele estava passando
a segunda história começa na minha
infância eu sou a terceira filha de duas
irmãs gêmeas e sempre foi conhecida como
avulsa e nas brincadeiras com as minhas
irmã e eu tinha dois papéis fundamentais
que sem eles a brincadeira não podia
acontecer
ou era árvore ou era o sinal de trânsito
e eu aprendia durante toda a minha vida
que alimentar é da amor é o amor vem
pela comida
as lembranças mais remotas da minha
infância são meus avós michel e magda
trazendo amor e afeto todos os dias pra
minha casa em forma de pão branco de
mortadela de latões de sorvete de filé
mignon on
meus avós me acompanhavam na natação e
remo direto comer uma coxinha de galinha
assim nos conectar vamos eu me sentia
amada e celebrávamos a vida
essa foto sou eu
aos 10 anos pronta para o carnaval e
sendo muito amado
até que na minha adolescência eu começa
a questionar os valores da minha família
como uma boa adolescente
o meu padrão de amor multa ea minha
auto-estima começa a ser medido em
gramas e eu começa então um processo de
anorexia
eu fiquei mais de um ano anoréxica
emagrecendo a cada dia
foi um período muito doloroso e sofrido
pra mim é como se fosse outro estivesse
competindo contra mim mesmo e eu como se
eu tivesse aprisionada dentro da minha
própria mente
por mais que emagrecesse eu nunca me
sentia satisfeita com o meu corpo e
minhas metas de emagrecimento mudavam
diariamente aquela era uma guerra minha
sem vencedor e sem fim
eu tinha uma agenda onde eu anotava as
minhas estratégias de guerra onde eu
anotava como eu me sentia
eu tinha dores na barriga e eu não podia
contar para os meus pais não podia
contar pra ninguém pois eu tinha que
sair vitoriosa daquela guerra eu anotava
também nessa agenda
os alimentos que eu pararia de comer um
dia eu resolvia que eu não comeria mais
pão e anotava na agenda e parava de
comer pão no outro dia parava de comer
sorvete no outro massa e assim foi um
ano durante um ano e eu no final eu
estava comendo cenoura minhas mãos são
amarela até hoje eu fiquei esse período
de um ano sem menstruar
até que um dia eu estava em casa com a
minha mãe toca o telefone
a minha mãe me obrigava a fazer exame de
sangue todos os meses e era do
laboratório de sangue ea mãe atendeu e
perguntaram pra ela se eu tinha sofrido
algum acidente ou se eu tinha perdido
baixo porque eu estava com anemia muito
profunda
naquele momento eu tive muito medo e
tive certeza que apoia morrer por falta
de comida não de amor e comecei então a
cura anorexia
aos 24 anos formada em economia
eu fui morar em nova york com meu
namorado que hoje é meu marido e lá
comecei a trabalhar no mercado
financeiro
eu substituir a competição contra mim
mesma da anorexia por longas horas de
trabalho e um trabalho altamente
competitivo
eu comecei a ter a crise de pânico e meu
chefe e mandava para o banheiro
até que na crise de pânico passar e eu
voltasse a trabalhar
aquele não era o meu sonho apesar de não
saber qual ele seria e eu vivia como se
eu tivesse no piloto automático me
sentindo um ratinho correndo dentro
daquele círculo mas lá trabalhando
diretamente com americano
eu percebi que eu tinha um espírito
empreendedor
aos 32 anos ainda trabalhando no mercado
financeiro
eu tive meu primeiro filho felipe e
parei de trabalhar logo depois meu
segundo filho joão nasceu e foi o
primeiro momento da minha vida em que eu
fiquei oito anos sem trabalhar
você estudar que eu resolvi que somente
iria nutrir meus filhos e foi nesse
período da maternidade que eu consegui
elaborar toda a minha história de vida
que meus avós passaram fome na guerra e
não tiveram um amor que na minha
infância eu tive muita comida e muito
amor
na minha adolescência eu tive sim comida
mas eu me privei dela eu me privei do
amor me privei do prazer e agora a
maternidade é quando entendia que o amor
prazer nutrição e comida podem fim andar
juntos
mas o meu pavor inter que alimentar bem
os meus filhos foi tamanho que eu fui
estudar sobre alimentos
eu poderia ter parado por aí mas foi
nesse momento que eu percebia que tinha
uma sementinha de um sonho muito frágil
dentro do meu peito e entendia que amar
é comer sim mas amar é comer bem
amar é alimentar a alma e que nós
mulheres gastam muito do nosso tempo e
da nossa energia pensando se a gente tá
gorda a gente está magra qual nosso
percentual de gordura
se a gente fez mais de nazca que as
nossas amigas e usa no tristão sempre
para emagrecer
esquece que a nutrição mais importante é
nutrir os nossos sonhos
a terceira história é sobre sonhos eu
vou falar do meu sonho mas eu queria que
vocês pensassem no sonho de vocês
numa viagem de férias no havaí os meus
filhos eu conheci os sucos prensados a
frio no primeiro gole do suco eu sentir
o imenso prazer e não sente culpa como
mais anoréxico quando entendia que o
método de prensagem a frio preserva
todas as enzimas todos os nutrientes sem
conservantes em choque térmico sem
pasteurização eu decidi que eu faria
primeira empresa de suco pensado no rio
de janeiro
eu encontrei naqueles suco tudo o que eu
achava de mais importante que era o
sabor o prazer ea nutrição e naquele
momento também decidir que eu iria falar
com o máximo de médicos de saúde
nutricionistas pra fazerem parte desse
meu projeto eu procuraria as frutas
brasileiras procuraria os melhores
ingredientes farias combinações com as
melhores funcionalidades ea minha missão
seria provar que apesar de saudáveis
os sucos sim podiam ser gostosa e
prazerosa da minha empresa eu sou
cliente mais chata
eu coloco o melhor de mim na garrafa
só que isso tudo não aconteceu em
desafio à logística resfriada num país
tropical a produção era diária as
compras eram diárias
o suco só durava três dias porque ele
não tinha conservantes pra ser sincera
eu não tinha a menor idéia e como fazer
essa empresa funcionar a ignorância foi
uma grande vantagem para mim
há três anos eu comecei a produzir sucos
na minha cozinha com essa máquina que o
trouxe de viagem em baixo do braço com o
meu marido reclamando
gaza e essas os primeiros sucos que eu
produzir e vendia para amigos realmente
olhando a foto não parecia nada
promissor e isso tem três anos e eu
neste momento eu aprendia que se a gente
esperar ter as condições ideais para
começar o nosso sonho
a gente nunca começa e as pessoas me
achavam maluca lhe davam argumentos
racionais que meu negócio não iria
funcionar
tentaram me convencer a congelar o
pasteurizar o suco praquele durasse mais
tempo mas aquele não era o meu sonho e
eu não ia tomar atalhos aquele não era o
melhor de mim na garrafa e eu pensei em
desistir
várias vezes eu costumo dizer empreender
no brasil é como um videogame ou a gente
morre ou a gente passa de fase
todos os dias mas eu não desistir
eu acreditei no improvável eu tive a
sorte de conhecer sócio com habilidades
complementares à minha e juntos com 103
funcionários que somos hoje o melhor de
mim na garrafa
virou o melhor de nós na garrafa e o que
me motiva é eu ver o sonho de cada uma
dessas pessoas que trabalham comigo
acontecerem dentro do meu sonho inicial
como por exemplo o caso da rebeca a
rebeca é a primeira funcionária é a
primeira pessoa da família dela fazia
faculdade ela começou no chão de fábrica
literalmente descascando abacaxi
depois ela foi cuidado de motoboy ela
foi abrir o nosso primeiro quiosque e
hoje é gerente de vários filhotes
isso tudo em dois anos e meio ea cultura
da oportunidade
é o que me faz ter mais responsabilidade
para que essa empresa dê certo e hoje
nós somos a única empresa de sucos no
brasil
que temos uma máquina de alta pressão
que mata as bactérias e preserva todos
os nutrientes todas as enzimas e fazendo
com que a validade que era de três dias
até quatro meses atrás
hoje os sucos duram 45 dias e hoje nós
somos a maior empresa de suco pensado no
brasil
o improvável pode acontecer e nos
momentos difíceis eu busco na minha
história familiar
os ingredientes que me motivam e
motivaram a construção desse sonho e
sempre lembro da história dos meus avós
o improvável pode acontecer que a sorte
pode estar do nosso lado mas que pra
isso tudo aconteça a gente tem que ter
muita garra e muita coragem e da próxima
vez que você via essa garrafa receba
todo o meu amor e pense no seu sonho e
eu te pergunto aonde você coloca o seu
melhor
o gado